بعوده للاوضاع في الخليل اطلقت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه النار على سائق
مركبه فلسطينيه عند مفترق مخيم الفوار
جنوب مدينه الخليل واصابته بجروح خطيره
بزعم محاوله دهس جنود على الحاجز العسكري
وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان احد عناصر
الجيش الاسرائيلي اصيب بجروح اثر تعرضه
للدهس قرب مدخل المخيم ونقل الى مستشفى في
بئر السبع
للعلاج
معنا من الخليل مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار
المزيد من المعلومات منتصر عن هذه
العمليه نعم مياده نحن نقف مقابل مدخل
مخيم الفوار جنوب الخليل حيث اطلقت قوات
الاحتلال قبل حوالي نصف ساعه من الان
اطلقت النار باتجاه مركبه فلسطينيه عند
مدخل المخيم الاعلام العبري يتحدث عن
اصابه احد الجنود
بالدهس بهذ هذه السياره التي تم اطلاق
النار عليها ويتحدث عن تحييد المنفذ ايضا
كنا تحدثنا قبل قليل لاهالي المنطقه هنا
قالوا انهم سمعوا اصوات اطلاق نار كثيفه
في اللحظه التي اطلق خلالها جنود الاحتلال
النار باتجاه السياره التي اطلق النار
عليها عند مدخل المخيم الان نحن نتحدث عن
تعزيزات عسكريه وصلت الى المنطقه والى
المكان قوات الاحتلال اغلقت المنطقه بشكل
كامل واغلقت البوابات الحديديه المؤدي الى
مدخل دوره الشرقي والى مدخل مخيم الفوار
وهي اصلا مغلقه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وانتشرت على طول الطريق الالتفافي الواصل
ما بين جنوب الخليل ووسطها وهي تجري
عمليات مسح وتمشيط الان في هذه المنطقه
كما يظهر في هذه الصوره حتى اللحظه نتحدث
عن وجود لسائق الذي اطلق او الذي اطلق
النار عليه لازال متواجدا حتى هذه اللحظه
كما يظهر في الصوره هنالك سيارتين اسعاف
متواجد جدتين طبعا فلسطينيتين متواجدين
عند مدخل المخيم قوات الاحتلال منعت
الاسعاف الفلسطيني من الوصول الى موقع
اطلاق النار وبالتالي حتى اللحظه سائق
السياره الذي اطلق الاحتلال النار عليه
موجود داخل هذه السياره ولم يتم تقديم اي
اسعاف له وكما ذكرنا الاعلام العبري تحدث
عن تحييده طبعا اضافه الى ان الحديث عن
اصابه جندي اسرائيلي في عمليه دهس كما قال
الاعلام العبري في هذه المنطقه طبعا هذه
المنطقه التي نحن نقف مقابلها تماما هي
تشهد هي تعتبر من اكثر المناطق ذات
التعقيد الامني هنالك نقطه وبرج عسكري
مقام عند هذه المنطقه بزود بكاميرات
مراقبه متطوره جدا وهي منطقه مفترق بمعنى
ان الاحتلال يتواجد فيها بشكل دائم هذا
المفترق يؤدي الى الى مخيم الفوار جنوب
الخليل وذات المفترق ايضا يؤدي الى مدخل
دوره الشرقي جنوب محافظه الخليل وبالتالي
نتحدث عن منطقه اجراءاتها الامنيه كبيره و
معقده ابراج عسكريه ونقاط عسكريه مقامه في
هذه المنطقه وتواجد دائم لقوات الاحتلال
تقع هذه العمليه عمليه الدهس في هذا
المكان المعقد امنيا وهذا ياتي بعد يوم
واحد من وقوع عمليه دهس يوم امس على مقربه
من هذا المكان الذي نقف فيه بالقرب من
مستوطنه عتنا عند مفرق وادي الشجني تحديدا
يوم امس كان هناك عمليه دهس ادت ايضا حسب
الاعلام العبره الى اصابه اربعه جنود
اسرائيليين الصوره كما تشاهدون هي تعقيد
امني وتشديدات واجراءات مشدده في المنطقه
هنا في منطقه مخيم الفوار شكرا جزيلا لك
من الخليل مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار